[Music]
so in 2006 an assistant who worked on
friends a writer's assistant sued the
show for harassment and I think it was
it wasn't a physical sexual harassment I
think it was verbal harassment and what
that show was able to prove to the judge
was that all that lewd talk in the room
did sometimes lead to story ideas and I
believe one was there's some episode
where Ross is like masturbating when
when one of the women walks in and he
switches the channel so it looks like
he's masturbating to a shark video and
that starts a whole thing and that came
out of people in the room talking about
jerking off so in that sense you know
the TV writers room isn't like most
workplaces
you know and and that's I think
sometimes hard for people outside to
understand that it can get personal and
it can get weird and sexual and
sometimes all three things at the same
time but the the judge said that the
assistant had you know not been in any
danger and that there they could justify
this language people have I think
misread bad in Hollywood to mean you can
say anything you want in the room which
is not true and and I think if you want
to have a non hostile work environment
you obviously have to be aware of other
people's feelings and levels of comfort
and making sure that everybody you know
it feels that the show is mission based
and you're all working hard to make the
best funniest episode you can when
you're on a set you know the difference
when a crew member brushes by you
because you're in
some type cranny and when the crewmember
presses up against you in a sexual way
and I feel the writers room it's the
same thing I know when someone I work
with is making a joke is is you know
just commenting on a woman's body in
order to make a joke or a man's body to
make a joke and when it gets threatening
you know and so I've gotten more vocal
as I've gotten older at going to people
outside the writers room and saying okay
that made me feel uncomfortable now the
problem with that is Hollywood is one of
those places where if someone acts
inappropriately
and you call them on it you're the
asshole
so that's one of the things I would love
to see change where you could tell
someone that made me feel uncomfortable
and instead of them being defensive and
saying I was joking they just went oh
well thank you for telling me
oh I'll be more aware of that in the
future
[Music]